yeah so everybody the dilemma for the
couple this time out is that whether
they decide to go back to the states or
Stan France are what they're going to do
next and I was wondering for all of you
has there ever been a situation in your
own lives where you have to decide maybe
in some le versus New York or anything
like that or LA versus France or
whatever in Paris has I've ever been a
situation you've had to deal with and
how do you do want something that big
the idea of the movie is that it's very
easy to look at a romantic relationship
when when there's an obvious bad guy you
know one person is an alcoholic or one
person is abusive
but for what if you were to take two
well-meaning people who actually love
each other and want the best for each
other
it's still hard and could we be that
portrait and I think anybody who's been
in a long-term relationship you run into
whether it feels as dramatic as Chicago
and there's it's whether or not your
lives are still growing on the same Road
and or does one need to change the road
to keep growing they still have to make
compromises and they all feel like who's
making the most compromise you know what
compromise might jeopardize their
relationship they love you know it's all
about like finding the right road and
the road is like you know it's like this
small for it not to fall apart you know
what I mean when you have a long-term
relationship it's always like you know
to make choices and do suit I mean
actually that relationships start with a
choice that Jesse makes which is to
follow his heart and but that comes with
consequences in the film starts with the
consequences of that choice you know and
we find them in a situation where they
have to make a choice again which is
like
she's spooning in her face that you know
you might want to invite to the States
but it might jeopardize their entire
life so you know that's that's the life
in the relationship I mean for where
they find themselves in life you know
and say the first movie for instance
they're attached you see how easily they
can get off a train and go home a day
later or just we learned they both
actually moved around a lot over the
years but when they were single and
unattached but now they're together you
see how difficult that is to maneuver
through life with one other person and
be on the exact same track
it's tough we will also take questions
for personalization sexual well I mean
no relationship question or need advice
unless you know what to do with five
cats but one of the interesting things
with this trilogy of films in particular
here are the long monologues and the
dialogues that one of the opening scenes
in the car
14 15 minutes when you are constructing
this are you cognizant that this is
going to be shot in one take and then
they're tossing in to children in the
back as well and one of the challenges
that creating that of creating that
particular kind of dialogue create for
us writers and performers and you
Richard as a director just mentioning
you mentioning that scene gives me like
a flashback of anxiety
the children because they're the unsung
heroes of that scene and they're not
asleep they're active little girls and I
have toys you know there's no way we
just in the middle of that take how did
they not open their eyes and a camera so
many things could have gone wrong
everywhere no way see of course for the
sound I mean like it's a whole
combination of things and then on top of
it we do have to act those 13 14 minutes
and you know nothing in those things I
mean already provides I just want to say
and everything is scripted and there's
no way any other way because since these
long takes like if you want to have this
this kind of Arc development in the
scene with this exact thing happening
there this exact thing happening there
is there anything with that it's it's
this in the sense of the whole movie you
can't add one line and basically it's
such a challenge I can't explain like
just like just to tell you it gives me
it hurts like I mean I know what these
guys can do as performers we've worked
together a lot over the years so I
wouldn't try that with most actors but
we've done it I know they can do it so
it's a lot of hard work but I know we'll
get there and it was just important I
think at the very beginning of the film
I think for people who feel like they
know Jesse and Celine to some degree to
just be drop-in with them the reality of
that of that Lethe take and with no
editing no telling you who to look at no
emphasis just the proscenium of you know
Jesse and Celine that you could just
feel like you're hanging out I think
that viewer has to accept that at some
point unconsciously as reality you know
so I think we're you know dropped into
their reality and everything
you're hanging out so that was just the
vibe that the film kind of needed right
off the bat so I mean I think what
Richard does and that seemed to me which
you know I very much respected suit to
actually do push us to get to that one
take what to me it does and he does that
in in its films especially in themselves
it's like those long uncut scenes to me
is really like by not using that typical
tricks of filmmaking which is short you
know cut cool sub medium shot that it uh
you basically break kind of like the
language of typical filmmaking and in a
way you kind of feel like you're
witnessing something that is not a film
and and it makes you feel very real I
mean it's the goal that you know he
wants to achieve which you know I
respect very very much and admire
constantly it's a very rare thing and
we're given that it's hard work but it's
also a wonderful thing to be able to do
is actually to see I want to tell us
that one of my favorite things about
these films is that they end leaving the
audience to kind of think about and
decide what will happen to the next will
a me - yes time will Jesse get on the
plane where will they go from here and I
wondered if in the interim between
making these films you ever think about
Jesse and Celine and what they might be
doing or where they worked in their
lives and also coming to end this film
where you think they'll go in future
have you thought about once doing
something ridiculous you know being in a
deli and trying to shop and buying some
things having a bunch of kids and with
me and you know and trying to talk to
the phone and and having this thought
like I wonder if this happens to Jesse
would this be a moment and while nothing
like that happened in the script you
over the period of years you collect a
few of those moments there's a certain
tone and a mood and theme - before some
resin before sunset and sometimes life
pops up and it is that and it logs in
there's something I mean we have to
think about they back sorry every time
we soak to write one line on the
screenplay
you can't start writing the second
screenplay or the third screenplay even
more without knowing everything about
what happened in between I wouldn't say
they live you know sitting lives with me
24/7 otherwise I'd be crazy but you know
there's a bunch of people at home watch
before success
and truly truly will let go of them but
then when we get back into working on
themselves it's like a tremendous amount
of like homework of figuring out what
happened during those nine years okay
and you can't even write a line of
screenplay
all those films without having done that
first and but we have the luxury of time
which is you know we have why did you
know it's like what you related to most
about Celine and where she is now in her
forties and and what aspects are part of
the emotional story resonate you the
most
I really wanted to make sure that she
was a strong woman she's a strong woman
she's looking towards the future she's
not someone who dwells in the past and
she's a very active person she's not you
know and she could see them at times you
know she's very addictive and she's not
gonna let someone tell her what to do or
how it should be done I mean she also
believes that if they do move to Chicago
it will destroy that relationship it's
not just about the work you know and
she's really convinced of that and she
probably she's right nobody I think
there is she she makes us sense you know
and to me it was very important that
she's not you know I mean she's not the
wife of the writer she's you know I mean
she's our own person and that's very
important for me to pick that character
I saw and it is the same for richer than
Ethan to make sure it's not this kind of
like you know the wife because otherwise
it's out of balance then it's not then
it's a film about a guy who was a nice
French girl from French life you know
you know it was very important and
it's very important to make sure it is
balanced female male that it's not a
match a movie or a feminist you know
movie without you no meaning or anything
that it's like very very balanced in
that sense and that's our goal actually
to make sure when we write this that it
is neither matcha or feminists or men
hating you know she's done a man-hating
what you know it's like the well you
know that we find the right balance
between the two where we cheeping you
know yeah continue so Matt well we don't
know yet I don't know I have no clue
Dean I actually don't think about the
future that's how we kind of I mean it
could be that could be yeah you know
it's not it it's fine it signs up a
trilogy we never planned it in the first
place
I think we're fine with it yeah hi um
over the span of 18 years how have the
characters and the story changing as
those performers are actors sings well
Julie the wreck their own films and from
the first one through the second won't
be coming to writers how this ends you I
like to say that I learned how to speak
on camera before summer that's like I've
never been as a young actor you kind of
get asked to pose or effect an emotion
or but Richard want to Julian I like the
gap to talk and to be present and from
the camera you know to not act and that
this adventure in not acting you know
hearted then
no nobody was thinking about that
because it's really hard actually you
really barely asked to do that as actors
maybe once in the film to have a big
model of telling a story you might have
it once every 10 films you know but
usually it's like I loved I loved I
loved I loved like what worked when what
might work but here it's like we have
big chunks like you should see the soup
you know and how do you do that without
signing it can sound really boring if
you're not super duper natural at saying
it like it sounds like we're really
telling the story to someone we care for
so that's the real challenge of
themselves and that's a that's that's in
this the challenge of the actors every
time and and as writers I mean we worked
on the same play of the first film but
you know like it was really hard to
learn to really talk on camera without
without being boring and that's the
hardest thing like to tell a story on
camera without something boring it's
it's the hardest thing I mean I think
serious it on other films and it's it's
really really hard you know so it's
finding the right you know if we evolve
that much I mean I think we the way this
was very similar to the way the dynamic
between us were a band who was still
performing in a very similar manner we
are the lyrics yeah we were in the
things the same the way we but the
result is the same the way we work
together one of the many things I loved
about the film is how raw emotionally
you guys are especially in the hotel of
sequence did you ever feel like you were
going too far or that you had to stop
and cry it out in between takes
audience member we're going oh my god
your question what do we ever go too far
usually if we think we've gone too far
that Julie in a spot we should explore
because what people think is too far is
usually to me it's like when you do this
things that are you know that stuff I
mean I feel actors I mean it's
pleasurable for an actor a little bit or
not to cry just suffer it's a it's it's
a pleasant thing that's already trained
for we trained to do it you know when
you see someone on camera crying and
being hurt they actually enjoying it but
it's painful it's the simple things
that's the hardest thing to find as an
actor and believe it or not the walk in
that beautiful village that we were is
actually more more draining as an actor
than it is you know I mean obviously it
is streaming as an actor to do scenes
where you're emotional and stuff but
there's a certain pleasure to it I can't
explain or maybe I'm weird not that
Jesse and Celine think it's funny but as
writers we know it's about is it was
challenging we know the two we were
locked in that word that rained for a
long time and you came out with a scene
we also were very this is the whole film
had been building tonight that was we
filmed that part of it in sequence so
for us it was a challenging yeah but we
were so glad to be there do it they
arrived where we've been worked for nine
years to get to so
tell you from Norway being in a created
relationship like this was so many years
what have you learned about yourself we
did that right off the bat is our
creative relationship beginner that's
the surprise my auditions for rig before
surprise this little you know romances
the idea that we would have this
lifelong collaboration that we would
have poured so much of ourselves
I mean it's that's the thing that's a
surprise the fact that we get to do this
and if somebody's interested I mean
that's a surprise I mean I mean what's a
surprise to me is that we do this home
we really work hard and the writing and
we really work hard on everything
directing and acting and stuff and then
not everybody will like themselves but I
mean some people really like it and it's
it's a strange feeling because we're not
trying to please anybody when we do the
film's we're really just trying to be as
true responsible this is not like a
publicity trick you know we just like to
be funny you're trying to entertain
you're trying to you know trying to be
dramatic this is something else anyway
like this last film especially writing
it I was like oh my god it's like I'm
you know like you go so deep into
certain things in the writing and
everything and even emotionally I mean
when I say
we're having fun during them the NC
we're having fun but it's also kind of
like moving a lot of things within us
it's not as simple as like having fun
it's also complicated you know those
emotions and stuff because we've all
been through those emotion in a
relationship and it's not a fun thing to
go through so we know how heavy it is
and stuff so it's really I don't know
it's just a very we just try to be as
genuine as honest as possible and what's
amazing is that people relate you know
and you know where sometimes I feel like
oh my god no one's gonna be interested
in this and this and that you know
sometimes you have doubts because you
like it so sometimes it feels so like a
deep emotion that people will be like oh
my god you know anything but you know in
the end some people can relate you know
which is I guess what cinema is about
for people to identify and write I don't
know or dream maybe it's less dream and
more identification ideal audience and
mine believe it or not I mean the second
film we felt no one wanted you know we
made the first film and no one ever
asked oh is it gonna be another film
that wasn't a logical question when we
were making the second film in Paris
every day we looked at one another in to
see how we could need to do this this is
amazing we're getting to make this very
personal film that no one really even
cares about three people which is
yearning good spot if you can ever be
making a film like that and and so the
way that one ended we there has been
this kind of build up we've all gotten
questions over the last nine years like
over Jesse's sleeve so we sort of
stubbornly rebelled against that in our
minds but once we let that go and put
out of our mind that there were even
three people out there who cared about
them and just kind of dug into ourselves
and concentrated on become that but we
do have this very small audience in mind
when we get to a crossroads and we think
oh whoa cinema storytelling narrative
language says if this was this equals an
unlikable character need you stop
we think well that's a construct that's
not really real it's the narrative you
know sorry tell me bubble them so much
cinema exists in we go oh you know maybe
our audience whoever that is might
appreciate that we go there and up on
this subject because we haven't built an
artificial they met can't support that
if you look at this no reserve you can
support a lot of brutal honesty we hope
you know the structure and before sunset
or midnight particularly they'd be
thrown out of any decent screenplay
class a 30 minute scene but we think of
our minds might get that they might
think that was cool you know I mean and
back from the first two films inform
this one you didn't mean like friends
and family could have loved you implying
yeah we have questions asked me to sign
the two books and talks about how
important their it's a slight homage of
us putting the fans in the movie you
know I mean it's it's this is something
about sunrise and sunset spoke soothes
people not you know the people that have
reached its spoke to them there's a
little homage to that there to me and
say oh I fell in love was my boyfriend
watch the film or you know we
reconnected after five years because I
so before sunset
you decided to call me up three so we
always hope for a few children
I feel like mother so I also really love
the dinner table scene so I'm sure you
saw that rehearsal process is different
given that you didn't know those past
members obviously as well as you know
each other but it still is intimate to
me
yeah well that was we thought that was
necessary you know for the movie to see
their social selves you know to see them
interact with other people the previous
two films were these kind of you know
bubbles into themselves so that was
purposefully you know designed for the
movie and the subject of that is kind of
romance at different ages or doesn't
endure so that's kind of with that that
seems about but it was a it was really
fun for us to pull ahead other people
into dinner scenes are tough they're
often boring they're hard to shoot
everything about a dinner scene is
challenging and it was fun to bring that
really wonderful group of people in and
into our process yeah there everyone is
very unique actually one of them I'd no
longer than do anything the the woman
who's roughly their age and that she's a
filmmaker and she ended up one of our
code co-producers she's a filmmaker very
acclaimed yeah I have to admit I have
not seen the first two films even though
I'm of the age group that you guys are
basically appealing to and I purposely
didn't see them before I went to the
screening to see if I could get this
film and I did very very much so I
wanted to know that's why you're making
this film do you guys think about that
at all that hey there's a whole bunch of
audience out there who has no idea do
you purposely think how can we draw them
in which why we did I was
you guys for the very beginning and the
second point is are you concerned at all
about being just specifically for a
certain age group in the screen that I
was at there was some 20 year old girls
who kept gasp every time Julie opened
her mouth she's an absolute or do
they not get her and I mean I got you
know good that made me think probably
someone who can express themselves no I
mean I think this poem is designed to
stand on its own I think it's a bonus if
you've seen the first two but absolutely
not necessary as well as the second and
we had some flashbacks there because we
really thought they needed this one it
it sort of answers any questions we hope
that you might have had coming out of
the last film but it tries to and this
was delicate in the writing it it has to
feel very not exposition but it had to
feel intertwined into the subject matter
you know that we would answer any
questions or refer to that just enough
but I'm glad they don't know none of
people have seen a movie to know to what
extent that works but that's you know
this great John Updike books a rabbit
books each one you can read it on its
own it's better if you read them
together and but that's the hope is that
these three each one should stand on its
own yeah it is interesting and I was
going to sing age range and they're
going up with kind of went through kind
of Sameera like experience
my question is location I know you guys
kind of pretty little bit scripts before
you went to the grease but how much the
locations interacting with local people
affect you guys the dialogue for this
one
being very impactful to the story it's a
major character
it's the third lead character in a movie
and it has been for all of them but it
comes pretty late in our process we
really just think about the character
and their relationship and then the
location for this one in particular can
pretty pretty late and but then once
once we're there we did most of our
writing in Greece we visited locations
meaning Clark we met people the actors
that we're going to be working with and
it infused itself into everything that's
kind of one of the joys of doing this we
really get to know a place and you
incorporate all that and even the great
political situation at the moment you
know we didn't want to be that film that
tells Greece anything about itself but
you know we did capture a moment the
Celine's paranoia about the situation
they're thinking the revolution was
imminent hi I just wanted to go back in
time to before sunrise when we were
casting the roles what might because
Ethan and Julie in the roles of Jesse
and Celine and Walker for Ethan and
Julie what make you to see yourselves in
these roles that you wanted to tradition
for them yeah it's a good question it's
our origin story I guess for all of us
how we I mean it was conventional I mean
I there was a script and I was going
through a casting process I remember I
met Judy very early she was like the
second actor I met on the film in Los
Angeles and I saw on a play in New York
Jonathan worked rodents off the street
and we talked after we got there but I
met a lot of actors in the bar for what
I was looking for was so high because I
knew what they would have to do to make
this one work so I was looking for the
two most creative you know inspiring
people I could find you know I didn't
know how to pull it off so it was
getting to after-school up for that
challenge we had other actors a day
early development before sunrise where
Rick told us you know we would get to
choose our characters names he said
their creation myth is I've never done
that nuts in this long thing of like
whoa which the character your own
character and I know having more
experience in film now I can't believe
that Rick asked us to be a part of that
these two young people to me to ask us
to such a dangerous thing to do I mean
it's such a difficult thing to do
many of those conversations especially
within the arguments are really familiar
to anyone who's in a long-term
relationship but what do you to learn a
Celine and Jesse as you're acting it
about how to handle conflict because I
assume when you're going through a
familiar fight as a character you have
more time to sort of process what you're
saying it's so nice to this is the ideal
argument I mean you know we get to write
it for like eight weeks you know we
rehearse things you wish you would say
yeah I mean like you know ice cream
don't argue very much so you know it was
a real stretch for me to it's a question
for all three of you please I'm
wondering what relationship wisdom or
advice we could give to or take from
Jesse and Celine the fun of this is you
just seeing the boards and all you know
I mean that's all we can do or all that
we've tried to do is try to put
three-dimensional real human beings on
screen and put them in a relationship
with each other and watch some age
twenty years even in that slit and you
can take from that whatever you can oh
you know he was a prick when he said
that he should like that's the trip we
don't have any advice about all we're
doing is trying to play off some reality
and the hope is by doing that somebody
else can use their wisdom and enjoy it I
don't know you know makes sense out
yeah dr. Phil will be here later yeah I
don't know relationships in place so in
relation to who you are it's so
impossible to even I mean you know we
explore one kind of relationship with
two kind of people and you know and
that's it and there's a million
different things that you know come into
any like it's impossible it's endless
you know in a way it is amazing because
I think human beings are endless things
to tell because there's endless
complexity to each of us and individuals
and that's always cool about the
location of Greece in Greece is this
places love stories thousands of years
and they always feel new humans yeah
there's anything hopeful it's really you
see a couple working through I've talked
to a lot of people now who are older and
they find the movie I think that's what
charged them up about the movie and made
them feel good is to see these two
people who are still trying you know
they're still communicating they're
making each other laugh when they can
and you see them in the ring you know
together I think often in relationships
one or both have kind of checked out if
you've got problems I'll deal with it as
minimal as they can't go back you know
you see a split there so I think it's so
cool and it's a good depiction of two
people who are actively working through
it they care enough that they're still
working through so for my character you
know I really wanted to make her really
a fighter because I felt that you know
so many people in a relationship kind of
give up but then they built more
resentment that if they were fighting it
at the moment they should be fighting it
and I think that's what destroys
relationship actually is when you know
when the woman or the man was
okay fine let's sit like that and then
they are never happy you know and I
think that's the end of a relationship
is when someone gives up the fight that
they really believe is what makes them
happy makes the relationship works etc
etc and you know the 20 year old that
was gasping every time they mouth she
doesn't know yet that's the secret of
making a relationship work you know
because she doesn't know yet which is
fine oh maybe she knows and she thinks
so no I don't know you know what the
truth is there's no rules of how to make
a relationship work and I don't even
know how to do it so you know my
previous question returned maybe at some
point you were afraid that maybe the
movie will be blow up by the clash of
egos of this you know health an
up-and-coming actor after they seemed
confused and then the French passionate
actress or they actually worked for good
for the movie but they were these two
passionate people yeah passion with
artists enough to put ego aside you know
we all have the egos I mean but you
realize it's not like being on a team
you were where do you fit in what's your
role we've always had this wonderful
process and if someone it's hard to
define yeah and it almost started we
clicked you know there wasn't that ego
friction that some people have innately
and some don't have we didn't have it so
we've always been able to bring really
strong points of view and a lot of
confidence in ourselves to a
collaborative effort and it's work
really friction free to them for the
most part it's Florizel process know so
it's kind of I think that's why we're
still the bands Celine because we were
talking about this the police after that
cities would be one of the most honest
women in terms of truthfulness that we
seen in cinema that she's so real in
terms of how she's developed and aged
and grown and now the kind of conflicts
she has as women of her age and I was
wondering if you'd ever reflect on that
that actually there aren't many women
like sitting in cinema in terms of the
kind of the level of truthfulness
everything her issues and some very
youngest movies and stuff in a sea of
obviously complaints women but I
remember as a kid growing up and be like
okay she's complex in in like Bergman
films that I see in some plays like it
that gobbler or like you know this is
very few like usually it's like one
dimension if you know is like a miracle
and like it's really hard to find
characters that are written in a way
that is truthful will two-dimensional I
mean she's not good she's not bad she
can be a can be adorable she you
know like how did you feel that and you
have that in male character a lot you
have like extremely complex extremely
conflicted characters and stuff and I
felt you know I always I mean there's
been characters like that too a lot in
like for example in cinema in the
seventies in the u.s. was wonderful in
the 60s and stuff it was wonderful then
it kind of died in the eighties like the
woman became one-dimensional again
something happened I don't know what it
isn't
anyway I just wanted to you know for me
it's essentially it's for us too because
we really work together it's not me
writing just silly you know and you know
I write tons of lines of Jesse but you
know and we all right for each other so
I mean we don't write for him because
he's a nobody we would other way
you know basically to make sure all the
characters really nicely dimensional and
really real and not some kind of cut out
you know cardboard of like a fantasy or
something like that I would never let
that happen anyway
with me in that room and they wouldn't
let me do that anyway so this is you
know Ethan has it strong and I think I
do too
these films are so balanced like we
really put our feminine side for Julie
put your masculine side forward and it's
I don't think we've ever been you know
out I don't think any of us have ever
felt like it was stacked against us I
think we're all supporting you know each
of these characters even you said that
you and Julie chose their characters
names I was wondering how you chose
Jesse and Celine what made you choose
those names I don't because it didn't
matter how they said it again when I was
a kid
a little more you know like less he px
Julie is actually super he P because it
was one at 69 like if you call Julie and
you're born before 84 like you have
parents that I just need to know you
know so Julian friend and my pet my
hands the comb a joke Julie Christie and
also Miss Julie but but so silly and I
thought was more like she's a more
conventional anymore you know straight
version of you know I'm a little crazier
than her so like the more straight they
like I probably were definitely be named
so he's my parents are a little you know
kind of parallel yeah more normal
parents it excludes my dad was